I can't stop smiling  kaley cuoco is smiling and gushing over  her man I can't stop smiling life is so  so good the Big Bang Theory star told  the ladies of the talk Thursday she  couldn't be happier with boyfriend Carl  cook  adding they initially bonded over their  love of animals they shared are  obviously our passion horses and dogs  and all that and it's been uh it's been  lovely I'm Kaylee even got candid about  life after divorce even deep down I'm  like I know that it this is just not the  right thing and the right thing is  coming for me I knew it I knew it I knew  it I'm just glad I got through it and I  am I couldn't be happier psych I think I  saw the light somehow